hey everyone welcome to
capitalize on you a series that hope
gary vee and i are hosting together we
are really excited about this
you know oftentimes especially with
women we have two taboo words money
and power and according to garyvee if
you cannot
own the concept of money and power you
are not going to be
successful so we thought we're all going
to come together we have different
perspectives different points of views
you've got hope tates
who is a money manager a money leader
knows how to make it knows how to spend
it and knows how to
be thoughtful about it so no better
expert than that
and gary vee who is a serial
entrepreneur who has made it who has
lost it who has made it
and and shares the best advice the good
bad and the ugly
um with with all of us uh for me i
am very involved in advancing women
making sure we know how to ask for it
not to be afraid to know our value to
know our worth
and to go for it because we all know if
you don't ask for it you ain't gonna get
it the worst thing that could happen is
you're gonna get a no
the best thing that can happen is you
get the yes
so a little new format today because i
just
think with hope and garyvee no better
experts in the world
the best advice comes from people who
have been there done that period
exclamation point
it ain't in a textbook it's about what
happens
on the street being a street fighter and
uh really having to
negotiate for yourself so i want to ask
both of you
a question which is what was that
first job you had that
really taught you the best life lessons
about what you were looking for
like what was that moment where you have
that job and it could start at any age
it could have been
you know you were sweeping the streets
it could be taking out the garbage
could be being a a waitress a waiter or
whatever server in a restaurant
what was that first job that really
catapulted you uh into where you are
today
hope so my the first one for me
shelley is pretty easy um i was 15 years
old
and i wanted to own my own destiny i
didn't want my parents to dictate
what i could and couldn't do and i came
up with the idea
of setting up effectively a canteen
at a tennis only club
and i literally bought the inventory
set set it up made the product sold it
so i had to actually
balance the numbers right understand the
purchasing make the sale
and every day account for what my net
profits were
and again if i got stuck and i spot too
much
and you know and it was stuff that went
bad and then i looked at the margin on
what i made
like if i put up an urn of coffee right
and how much i made on every pot and
it taught me to understand inventory
taught me to understand
margin it taught me to understand how
important it was to get
you know money into my own pocket and
how i could drive the destiny
and then you know learning how to market
it like telling everybody what i had set
up
and sort of advertising it so i was a
one-man
oompa-loompa band and that that's what
taught me
uh the importance understanding it from
top to bottom and i didn't know a lot
about finance at that point
um but i i knew that i had the drive
i could do it i could do it on my own
bicycle
um i had a backpack you know bringing
the goods there
um and i learned about customer
experience too
and you can't forget because you weren't
driving a car you were riding your bike
so you didn't have to put that into your
spreadsheet
i wasn't all i wasn't old enough shelly
i didn't have a license
garyvee what about you you know listen
the only person i've ever really worked
for
is my dad and you know if my dad was
here right now
he would make a face because by the
second day i was in that liquor store
i was over communicating to my father
about the 97 things that i thought we
could do better
um for me it's a little bit of a
different thing i think
you know and i really mean this and i've
said it for anybody who's been watching
and i'm glad she's got the hat you know
what the framework of this show
you know is around money i you know i'm
an incredibly basic
money executor and i do think there's
incredible power in
in simplicity and i want to bring that
energy here
i think hope is a far more
501 601 class to my 101 class
let me explain what i mean i have
basically been in a very binary
simplistic game
of understanding supply and demand i'm
very good at that
it comes very natural to me whether it's
the craziness of sports cards right now
that nobody could see whether it was the
attention
on social networks i've always been so
darn good at it because i've always had
good intuition of what consumers were
gonna do
which gave me an advantage of where
demand was gonna come and if i could
understand supply i could make good
decisions
very similar with my money i've just
never spent more than i've had
now grow in a lot of ways that kept me
conservative in a lot of ways where my
money could have worked better for me
and we can get into that
but you know i learned truly on the
streets of lemonade
you know it's snowed like hell here um
uh two days ago in new york
and my sister called me and she's like i
always think of you when it snows still
to this day
she's like because first you would pray
to god that we wouldn't have school
all day you'd be nervous for the next
day is it gonna melt is that you know
what time is the storm because i've
figured out
they could call off school but then more
importantly
everybody would go immediately into play
mode and i would go into work mode
i would shovel snow 80 of the time in my
youth
so for me i learn and this is why i am
who i am
i learned from the market not from a job
i learned ding dong ding dong ding dong
knows
i could handle no's which is why i'm an
entrepreneur
but i wanted to learn from those right
and that
you know from a very early age like an
athlete or an entertainer i was
practicing my craft so my learnings
came from market dynamics more so than
let's say
a job you know i think the biggest thing
i learned at my job is why i think i
talk a lot about culture my dad
managed shoppers discount liquors which
is what the name of the store was before
i changed it to my library
in a very soviet way the employees are
your enemy
you know don't trust anyone it was a lot
of fear and negativity and
and i would argue that my 14 to 18 year
old career in that store
probably made me who i am today as an
operator
in a lot of ways i naturally had it but
i saw what didn't work
about having that kind of thing and so i
learned how to be a culture driven
operator both from my natural dna and
the way i was parented by my mom
and then by being visceral to be frank
on the way my dad ran
his store i used to be mad at him i'm
much more understanding it's the culture
he grew up in
so i don't judge him as much as i did as
a kid that i learned a lot about what i
didn't want to do
the first five years of my job at my
dad's store i think that's amazing the
one thing that still
keeps me up at night is i have no idea
where my kids pokemon cards are
and when you talked about sports cars
i'm like where the heck
are the [ __ ] pokemon
cards those first editions they're worth
i mean what's going on in that world is
nuts go ahead
yeah gary i found them i found them for
you they're coming your way
shelly the key i think gary and i are
saying one other thing
we relied on ourselves actually
we relied on the desire to earn money
right and then figured out the skills or
what we could do or capitalize on
and this why this whole series is so
important what we could do to capitalize
on ourselves
to and gary is so great about you know
garage sales and
and and getting out and ways to make
money
where you everybody you can do it and we
want to help you
take control of your own financial
destiny money
money i apologize money is a you know
and i'm just become infatuated with this
word
i think one thing we're talking about as
an undertone here for everybody who's
listening
is accountability
you know i you know when people are like
well
this that i'm like i can't stop thinking
back to the point here
the amount i'm reading all the comments
right now pamela t amanda w what's good
leo i just and i'm not joking every time
we do the show it's like the fifth time
i'm like i wonder how good they are at
saving
because people blame everything and then
you know especially and these are people
that i
when i know somebody i'm like yeah but
you bought a bmw nine years before you
probably should have
because you're you needed to flex and so
you were spending
200 more a month on something you like
that's like
people are not very good at the
relationship of not only
you know hope and eye story was about
control right you know but as kids we
both you know i was listening to her i'm
like oh i get it i didn't want anybody i
don't want anybody have any control over
me period and a story about anything
but then you take on accountability
people give up people don't like
accountability so they give up control
but i think managing your money is a
very very interesting framework around
this
well i think that one of the things you
both are clearly
identifying is you need to depend on you
the one thing you can control the one
thing you could be accountable for
is your choices and you know living with
intentionality
um we have an amazing guest that we are
bringing on
um so i i want to do that introduction
and it is such a perfect
segue um arena novoselsky
who is the chief executive officer of
career builder
how do you build your career uh one of
the things that
you know i have completely valued and
gary you said this
is the nose the nose also lead
to the yeses you know and so next
next show we'll talk about what no led
to your best
yes and how you found yourself in that
but we are going to talk to arena
about um how you find your value your
worth
and a career that is satisfying i always
say when you love what you do it's
called passion when you don't
it's called stress so with that welcome
arena and hope i am going to turn it to
you
arena we are we are so delighted to have
you
and before we begin and i go into
questions
why don't you give the audience listen
we are trying to elevate the audience
we're trying to help the audience we're
trying to help them build their careers
we're trying to help them build their
their their pocketbooks
give a little bit of background on you
you are a remarkable woman
you have built your own career give us a
little bit of background
that's so kind hope good to see you
shelly good to meet you gary i have to
tell you i feel like we've been on
parallel
lives in some way so um it's funny when
i was uh meeting with the team for this
podcast
they shared we're from uh pretty similar
cities in
in the ussr and then it turns out we
grew up
in the town next door in new jersey
where are you from
um nobody knows this so i never really
share it but it's from old bridge
oh yeah so close to edison that's
amazing i used to play your tennis team
were you were you born in the soviet
union or did you were you born here
no i was born in kiev and we immigrated
as
refugees very similar in the in the late
80s when i love it they uh
allowed the opportunity so it's a real
pleasure to have you here
thank you i'm glad to be here um hope to
to your point um
a little bit about you know you i i came
in just as i think shelley was saying
the difference between passion
and stress um and one of the reasons
that i'm at careerbuilder is just i have
such
passion for work and especially as an
immigrant
one of the things that i really saw both
from my parents who were
highly educated in the ussr my dad was a
an engineer with a phd my mom was a
chemist very
stereotypical soviet jobs um and when
you come here it's very difficult how do
you translate
all your experience into you know an
american
version resume and so i watched the
thousands and thousands of resumes
that my parents would send out and we
came here during the recession in the
late 80s and so
that was even more difficult and i very
quickly saw
my dad take the phd off his resume the
the other masters off his resume to kind
of allow himself to be
picked up on some of these roles and one
of the things that really became clear
to me over growing up with
not a lot of money at all um is that
independence that you talked about that
accountability that
having that control over your own um
life and one of the things that really
highlights to me is just
over time and we're seeing it now with
covet is that work and having the
ability to get a job is such an
equalizer
whether it's an economic equalizer it's
a gender equalizer it's race
and so one of the things that is just so
exciting from a passion perspective
at careerbuilder is that we get to put
people to work
we get to empower employment and we work
with
all of the fortune 500 and a lot of
small and business
companies helping them figure out how
did they change the face of their
companies
making sure that they're hiring a
diverse workforce and then working with
over 160 million americans to help them
match up
finding the right passionate job for
them
arena what you do is remarkable and you
know how much i care about
diversity and inclusion and esg and and
you are helping companies uh get
meet their goals our audience there are
a lot of people who are either looking
for a job
looking to transition uh out of a job
what kind of advice do you give them
with regard to salary
flexibility you know equity and where
they work
like what what's the good fits and
benefits what are the top advice
you you want to give the audience yes
and so much they need jobs
yeah so much good stuff of what you and
what you said hope and i i would start
with
i i don't remember if it was you or gary
that said this but early on
you you mentioned how important you both
really leveraged your skills in your
career
and really put your strengths forward
and the number one piece of advice that
we would give candidates
is really leading with your skill set
and what what does that mean and it's a
little
different than the traditional way that
matching
work has been done in the past and we're
really trying to help modernize that and
one of it
is not asking the question of have you
done that job before
have you had that specific experience
but asking can you
and that is a skill set related
mentality
and it's highlighting those skills
because especially in this disruptive
world of cobit
you may never have had that kind of role
or you're trying to take a chance
or as a company you want to change the
demographic of who you're constantly
hiring into that role
and that requires having a little mental
flexibility to really be asking
what are other skills that you have that
you've exhibited
in very different in different roles
i'll give you a really easy
example flight attendants we've clearly
seen flight attendants really being
pulled back from a demand perspective
and one of the things that our
technology matches them based on the
skill set
is customer service reps which is one of
the fastest growing
roles right now and so none of them have
had that specific
experience but most of them have that
overlapping skill set
marina i want to ask you a question to
you but also hope and gary
which is you know today we talk about
the best leaders the best employees
are empathetic and passionate what is
the best
question you can ask to get at that
because you know i hire for passion
praying for skill unless you want black
lawyer an accountant can you say that
again shelley i really like that i want
to use that i higher compassion
i train for scale but if we're not just
looking at where you went to school and
all that stuff that we all have clearly
said
that doesn't necessarily translate into
a great employee
what is the best question you have asked
in an interview that has gotten you
this soulful passionate employee and i'd
love to hear how garyvee and
hope you know think about that too so
what a good question i wish i wasn't
going first
i'll tell you too so empathy is is so
hard also in an interview you you want
to make sure that this person is relaxed
a little bit so you can really start
understanding
the true self of them and so i use two
questions to try to understand that
one is i asked to tell them about ask me
to tell them about their childhood
i find the minute that you ask somebody
to give you kind of their upbringing
first of all they start smiling because
they usually talk about something that's
near and dear to them
and all of a sudden you see kind of the
walls come down um so that's been a good
one and then the second thing
is i asked about give me some examples
of what you've done with your team um
and people go in different ways they
sometimes talk about a social setting
sometimes they talk about problems
they've overcome but immediately
you start to pick on up on where they
see themselves within the team are they
a team player
um do they mention a lot of the eyes and
so you start to get a little bit of
insight into that
i'm curious to see what you guys are
gonna say i heard something great you
know
it's that when you say i i i and you
have this huge team
someone said to this um person once well
if
you're doing everything you don't need
the rest of the people
get rid of all of them make them go away
garyvee what's your favorite question
you know i take a very interesting
approach when i'm hiring
i i actually go into every one of those
with the thought of i need to give them
context and
and make them under like i feel like
it's my responsibility even
when it's a very junior role i feel like
it's my responsibility to do a couple
things one i'm incredibly passionate
to make them feel wildly safe so they
tell me the truth
so that's important to me two i'm
incredibly
candorous around who
wins and doesn't win in my organization
mainly
so that they can opt out like one of the
things i've been talking a lot about
lately is like look
if you have a good sense that you're
insecure this is going to be a really
tough place for you to win
because we think that insecurity really
leads to the kind of behavior
we're hyper sensitive on culture i don't
know what else to say
like it takes almost everybody that
works for me a full year to calibrate
because they think because when they
come from the outside they think what
was acceptable behavior
like the delta between acceptable
behavior at vayner and somewhere else is
like literally the way you look at
someone
versus like you know like cattiness
versus like
mean like there's a big delta so i try
to get people to feel safe
you know it's funny every now i'm very
very very big on childhood questions too
i like context from the beginning but
it's more about me trying to give them
the clues to the organization
because i don't i think people fear i'm
trying to get people to fear this less
they fear the short-term stay in their
resume because they think it's a
vulnerability somewhere else
and so i feel a huge sense of
responsibility as type of business owner
that is willing to make a quick decision
when somebody's not emotionally
intelligent
and so i don't want to put that scarlet
letter on their resume
when they're only going to be here for
six months so i'm spending a lot of the
time
giving them the truth making them feel
safe
and then hopefully they'll give answers
so that's we i take that approach
you know gary it's funny you said that
because one of the things we're seeing
with our clients is they're spending a
lot more time
interviewing for fit which is
essentially what you're saying
and they're they're reversing it and
they're trying to exactly like you're
saying figure out
are you not a fit or are you a fit
pretty quickly before they even get to
the
can you do the job yeah i'll be honest
with you arena i don't even
i don't even spend a minute on can you
do the job i make the assumption that
you can
slash if you can't we're gonna speed
that up pretty quickly slash
it's just secondary and arena i
completely agree i mean listen i ask
people to go to their happy place
you know because to try to get a sense
of what makes them comfortable because i
think you
have to like what you do right
if you fear what you do and you don't
like the people
that's where the fit is terrible so
i want to see the authenticity i
actually ask you know what was your
worst experience
at work and you know how did you handle
it and how did you know your boss or
your team handle it
but i before i asked that question i
actually tell them what mine was
because they need to see me as authentic
and caring and open to refl
self-reflection
because this is all about working in a
team it's
you know i talk all the time about
throwing the ladder down and pulling
somebody up
right i want somebody who wants to climb
that ladder
but i you know it has to be a
combination of the person atop
throwing the ladder down so i think you
have to make yourself
vulnerable a little bit in an empathetic
um and talk even a little bit right now
during covid
be honest kids are coming in on people's
laps it's not perfect i've heard
he's crying it's happening and the
empathy
and getting people not to say oh i'm so
sorry that
you know somebody walked in on the room
let's put that aside
right we have to be much more self-aware
and and and open to other people's
challenges
and we have to be vulnerable ourselves
so that we feel we also went from
working at home to living at work
so it's changed everything so we also
talk a lot about the human ceo
and bring your human to work because
we're all human
you know we are so far from perfect and
i think our imperfections are our
perfections
but i think it's also amazing you know
as we're talking about capitalize on you
you know what's your best advice for
knowing your value you know so many you
know people especially tuning in
you know want to know know their value
and ask for their worth do you have
advice on that
yeah there's two questions in there
shelly they asked one is knowing your
value and two you're kind of saying how
do you negotiate for your value
um and on the knowing your value
sometimes it's as basic
as writing it down and what i mean by
that
is a lot of people spend a lot of time
highlighting their weaknesses and the
things they think they need to improve
on and i'm just such a big believer of
capitalizing on your strengths
people we talk about passion and when
you like what you're doing and your
passion for your job you end up being
better at it
and so the things that you're usually
better at are your strengths
how do you lean into that how do you
make sure that the role that you're
going for
capitalize on your strengths and a lot
of it starts with write it down
what are you good at what do you like
doing and sometimes those aren't the
same things
we sometimes are good at things that we
don't really love doing and so having
uh self-awareness to recognize that is
step one
and then the second part of your
question is how do you capitalize on
your strengths
a lot of times is asking for it and yeah
i think i don't remember if hope said
this or gary on one of your earlier
podcast but it resonated with me because
i say this all the time but
you can't get something that you don't
ask for and so how do you lead with your
strengths and whatever it is the worst
thing that can happen is you get told
now
but in that no you get so much knowledge
because you can ask
why not you you also have to calibrate
that
one there's way too many people that are
have over
expectations they just do they're
delusional
b i worry when people think about
i i would i arena you know how i think
about it a little bit differently than
knowledge
because i i'm stunned by how many people
take one other human being subjective
opinion as gospel i think of it as a
data point
context and depending on who's telling
you that that's awesome
my whole life is like judge the judger
yes
right like when i like when i was being
judged for my entrepreneurship
by teachers and parents who are not
entrepreneurs
even at 1314 it didn't carry weight with
me i'm like you don't understand the
game i'm playing
one of the things that i'm very
passionate about is just because your
boss didn't think that you were worth
not worth another ten thousand dollars
that doesn't make it
true it makes it true in this
circumstance which oh by the way
you have no idea of what's going on in
the macro situation
they might think you're worth 40 000
more are dying to give it to you but
they got a shitty situation brewing
over here but so many people take it as
the truth
i think that's so critical gary the the
power of mental know
and so much of what especially with kobe
we're spending a lot more time talking
about mental health
and what that means but that positivity
in your brain and really
paying attention to who is saying no to
you who's giving you that negativity
and either taking them out of your world
or focusing on that positive but
you know for every every person that
says yes there's hundreds of people that
say no to you across your entire career
i'm sure
shelley and hope you guys have some some
good nose stories as well but and
one last point irene i apologize the
other thing that i want to remind people
is back when we brought it up already
accountability guess what
you get to know most people not most
that's not fair
a stunning amount of people decide what
happens next is dwelling
and poisoning go forward
yeah it's like quit this goes back to
savings
the amount of people right now that
can't quit their job because they're
spending their entire salary
on materialistic or other variables
right
like savings gives you the options
for when you get no and you know
there's a lot of people in the comments
like gary i don't have any savings i'll
barely be i'm like
you get every money you're spending like
people bought homes and have more
you could pay 500 less than rent you
could you could
you know people are not willing to you
know irena you and i have a huge
advantage
of starting poor don't yes
i'm being serious dirt dirt mentality
helps you
i have friends telling me they can't
save anymore i'm like
you're out of your mind you're fancy
you're [ __ ] i'll tell you i'll tell
you
a personal story that i don't think
before i
got a job and moved out of my house i
don't think i've ever walked into a
starbucks
meaning i never ever would think of
purchasing coffee outside or a
restaurant
i mean those things were just such a
luxury that i didn't really
afford myself until i was i was i swear
to god until i was 15 years old this is
true no joke let me go a little bit
until i was yeah until i was 14 15 years
old i
swear to god i thought red lobster was a
premium restaurant
me too gary i will tell that i
i remember for my 16th birthday i
so badly wanted for my sweet 16
to go to red lobster with my parents
because i thought that was the most
luxurious
and by the way i still do love red
lobster
different context and this is
perspective and all of a sudden
when i'm eating and [ __ ] per se and
having a caviar and a [ __ ] egg i'm
like wait a minute
this you know you have perspective but
if you've only been eating caviar out of
a [ __ ] egg
you're like i can't save i but you know
what to bring this back to
people that are looking for jobs and
negotiate one of the things i will say
is
we don't see that pay being the number
one reason people leave companies or
jobs right it's the engagement in the
company do you like your boss do you
like who you work with do you like your
team do you feel included do you feel
engaged
we're seeing a lot more of even i just
spoke to a fortune 500 ceo
and we were talking with him of how do
we help him get
tools within his company to engage his
employees and so
pay is definitely one of the items but
we're seeing
not fall in the top three i think hope
you mentioned benefits that is coming up
much more
and giving that flexibility especially
to working moms that we're just seeing
exit the workforce
in in disproportionate ways flexibility
life stage accommodation you know
understanding that we all are at
different stages of life and if
we want to attract and retain our best
talent we need to accommodate around
that
and and by the way all the benefits and
the long-term benefits that actually can
make you
save for your future right and and it's
really important that people
look at the whole package how are you
talking to people about looking
at the whole package where you're
working what the flexibility are what
the benefits
and how you actually save money gary you
know our audience
definitely is having a hard time we want
to help them
think about how the opportunities they
are could save
and carve out money spending less is
obviously one thing
but how do they other things they can do
in the work environment
to help them understand the opportunity
to save
to put away money in a in a 401k etc
arena what ideas do you do well i would
say from a roadmap perspective i hope
there's definitely some short-term
things that you can look at
from whether it's cutting expenses or
some short term finding opportunities to
make more money but
really the way you change your
trajectory is
again going back to the skills one of
the things that we we even do on the
curribular.com site is you put in your
skills your job your skills
and it tells you if you want to make
more money what other skills do you need
to get that next
role and that that really that self
training that self certification
is really the evolution of where we're
going it's much less about a four year
standard degree
it's less about paying for this higher
education
it's figuring out what certifications do
you need what skills do you need
to go from the job that you're in now to
the next jump whether it's five ten
thousand dollars more
how do you arm yourself to be considered
for that next role whether it's in the
existing company you're in or the next
company
and it starts by knowing where are you
on your skills what are you missing and
where can you go and there's so many
free tools now
we sync to a lot of the free tools but
there's plenty out there as well
that allow you to manage your own career
and going back to that accountability
line
control your own career well it also
goes back to the upskilling in the
moment you don't need the four-year
education
you know it what skill do you need now
and there's
so many ways of accessing that i mean
gary you speak
about this all the time you know it's
not necessarily
you know in the four-year education it's
within the moment and you can get access
to what you
you you want get access to what you feel
you need
and we see that the majority of the
candidates and when you think about the
the u.s population the majority of the
u.s population does not have a standard
four-year degree
that's really only about 30 percent and
so
when when we think about both our
candidate universe and the majority of
u.s americans
they're looking for other options to
your point shelly
so arena oh i'm sorry go ahead hope
i'm going to put you on the spot for a
second why do you think that men
have an easier time building wealth or
getting that job than women and how do
we change that
uh i want to pivot that a little bit um
and
here's how i think it starts right now
we know that there's an economic
discrepancy that happens that women get
paid 82 cents on the dollar so
right there you're starting with a
little bit something that we as leaders
whether it's on this phone or anybody
that is in the power of hiring
it's on us to change that dynamic and
making sure that we're really driving
wage parity but that really translates
into material dollars it's uh for an
average american that's ten thousand a
year that's almost half a million
dollars
over the course of a career so that's
one thing the second thing
is again going back to the skills and
really understanding
where are you trying to position
yourself so if you think about
covid one of the things that we talk
about is that women are
disproportionately impacted by what's
happening in covid
and a lot of that is because women
there's a disproportionate amount of
women in hospitality roles
so if you look at restaurant waiters
about 70
of restaurant support staff is women
and so when you think that restaurants
are being the most impacted
it's driving a lot of that and so that
doesn't mean you should exit industries
but in a world that things are
disrupting so quickly how do you take
your skill set
and pivot quickly into another role and
really leverage there's so much
technology whether it's herbal or other
tools there's so much tools out there
to get in there and understand with your
skill set what role could you be
best suited for and then you're gonna
say one thing
waiters in restaurants are also
the best employees because they
understand what we were talking customer
service
and we talked about iq customers
problem solving in their dna i can't
tell you i i had this one story we were
at a restaurant and i just thought this
this waitress that was serving us was
just so thoughtful
high eq communicative i asked her if
she's looking for a sales job
i wanted this person on our team and so
i mean i've done the same thing i've
like literally hired like it's by the
way
on the spot warby barbie jung yes i'm
reading the comments during this talk
i'm i'm listening on both sides because
i use the context of the feedback of the
audience
and this conversation to give me
thoughts of things that i could bring
value to this combo or in the future so
that was to answer you
keep going ladies no i
arena i think you're so right i love
your story about
the flight attendants right and customer
service
customer service is a huge opportunity
upskilling
uh you know and pivoting is a great idea
give us some other great ideas that we
can help the audience to find
better jobs and make more money and
ultimately
be in a position to save sorry gary
actually i want to add to it because
something that i'd love to get your
perspective on irena that i've had a lot
of
intuition around and i've seen some
people follow when i've thrown it out
there and have high success
i mean why or do
so i guess both i feel like people limit
their at-bats when looking for a new job
i am fascinated that it's 2021
and we have a world where a bunch of
people can be in a community and
make a shorted stock go up to 300 a
share we'll ask cope about that in
another episode
i don't think people know how to use
technology i'm not saying that you
should spray and pray
and run and run an algorithm of machine
learning ai
and spam every business but in today's
world
it just feels like you can send 31
resumes instead of two
and i feel like is there a subconscious
massive fear of getting 31
no's like so many people who've heard me
talk about this and i don't talk about
it a lot
but i get so many emails to this day of
videos from a year two three four five
years ago
and they're like garyvee i was
struggling for nine months because i was
unhappy
i saw you in the interview you said this
and god damn it i did send 100 resumes
and i got my job like there's i'm a
little bit concerned about people not
giving themselves more at-bats it's just
it's not like the old days when you had
a knock and go and fine i could
you had kids i don't i get it now it's
literally right here is there something
there i mean like can we get
and i will i'll share from both sides
and it's it's a dynamic that's changing
so what you're seeing is actually the
evolution
of uh an approach so from an employer
perspective and for mechanic perspective
technology has massively changed i i
will tell you
the career boulder matching engine and
if you think about it it's literally on
match.com
where we take everything that we know
about you as a candidate
everything that the employer is looking
for and then we have a percentage match
it's the netflix
you're most recommended to watch this
movie kind of match right and so
the thing that we do is and this is the
technology at work exactly what you were
saying
is we'll look at your background we'll
look at your skill set we'll look
actually at the one or two jobs that you
applied
and then we will give you
recommendations of another 25
that have over a 95 match and with one
button you can literally
apply to all of them and on the other
side we're doing the same matching for
companies because they're saying i love
gary go get me ten more gary's
and we literally take gary's background
put it in let's not
let's our search engine maybe 10 is too
many but a few more
um gary's and you you literally put it
in the search engine
and then we get a hope we get a shelly
that literally gets recommended for them
and
that technology it's it's early we are
early on that technology curve and one
of the things that we're seeing with our
successful clients is
they're embracing it and those that are
are watching they're missing out on on
some good talent and efficiencies in
their org
and irene i just want to say because the
bias barriers and with
implicit bias especially in resumes and
matching and ai
and algorithms and all of that you know
if you put
mom on your resume or pca
it typically is a ding but if we
can create the right data sources of the
skills
that the waiters you know have and i'm
saying waitress
flight attendant mom a mom can multitask
on steroids has
empathy um is the ceo of a household
you know all the skills we need to also
bring that in
to the algorithms that we're creating
where we are
not making being a mom a a barrier but
actually an opportunity of an amazing
you know employee you know on the team
definitely and on the other side
one of the things that candidates really
watch is the job description
you'll be surprised we've done we do a
lot of testing where we'll put two of
the same job descriptions and just
change a few words and which one will
candidates
click on and the words that are used by
companies to describe their job
is one of the most important keys for
getting a candidate to click on your job
or not
and so one of the things that we provide
our recruiters is we give them insight
on which words
are not really gender neutral that are
discriminatory and it could be words
that we use
every day i don't associate with this
particular word i don't think shelly or
hope will either with this comment but
rockstar in many cases dissuades women
from applying clearly not for this
audience i think everybody
in this audience is assertive directive
you know those are all words that are a
little off-putting because we don't see
ourselves that way versus empathetic
collaborative compassionate
nurturing team builder exactly and so to
your point
it's not only just capturing that
experience but making sure we're using
the right words or another thing that
we're seeing
and you guys mentioned this earlier is
there's good gaps in people's resumes
and especially now with covid how did
you really pull the skills from that gap
whether you were taking care of an
elderly family member
their skills in that that you can
highlight to to show that during those
months
you had to do a lot of logistics
communication
your empathy your patience those are
things that are necessary for
every job arena what you are doing
a career builder and and getting people
to
match match perfectly and and employed
and giving them hope um you know so
honorable we love to ask on this show
what is your advice to your younger self
i apologize before you answer that
question i just want to say goodbye to
the audience because
i have to run to a hard stop but ladies
take it away and everybody in my
community on my channel is watching this
keep watching this brilliance and irene
i hope we get to meet in person i love
the
shared background thank you gary shelley
so arena because we're always tight on
time
what's the advice what's the advice
you'd give your younger self what's your
advice you'd give this audience
that they can be you you have a
remarkable career
you've been a woman in a man's world you
have done so much
we all take our hats off to you what's
your advice to your younger self
um i hope i get to hear yours hope too
but one of the things i would say and we
talked about this
is tune out the negativity we you know
we spend so much time
processing the negativity we hear the no
and just
tune it out and really continue to stay
focused on the positive
and just reaffirming to yourself you can
do it and keep moving forward and just
not let any of that negativeness get in
from from a candidate perspective what i
would tell all the people out there
looking for the right job whether it's
they have a job or they're not
it's same thing keep going you will find
it it is
out there and a lot of times you just
have to push through the no
through the not today and just
continuing to
to show up and keep batting so
arena i think that's unbelievably great
advice i agree
it's play for the long game don't be
afraid you know you might
fall get up you know pivot keep going
um and also keep using your network
you know we say and we've done we're
doing this podcast reach out
keep lifelong learning about
opportunities you know
go to sites like careerbuilder do so
that you can
have a better future and again i say
reach out to me we're all here to help
we're all here to make a difference
and we love the three of us love being
around strong women
um and by the way my advice to my
younger self
yeah i want to hear it i i never thought
of myself as a girl versus a boy
um you know something so funny hope
neither did i i just did not associate
with gender until others put that on me
i just thought forward so
let's challenge things together
i i think for me it's um i it's realize
your differences are your greatest
strengths and don't let others define
you
you need to define yourself because
that's where authenticity is
you can fake it once or twice and try to
be someone else but you can't
consistently
be someone else you have to be you and
be proud and believe in yourself
and if you believe in yourself others
will so i think that's the truth
so this has been wonderful you are arena
you are such a role model to so many
uh people i'm not going to say women
your role models is so many people
um we love having you on uh you've
pulled up
so many and let's hope we can keep doing
that on this show
and keep building everybody's hope for a
better future
i love that i really love what both you
and shelly are doing
keep doing it and thank you for
including me today you're awesome
thank you awesome thank you bye